across parts of southeastern including
the london area we've had our first ever
red weather warning here for the strong
winds and that means we're looking at
gus up to around 80 miles per hour over
an area that's very populated so it's
not great news as we've already heard
and the strong winds here the warning
out the red weather warnings out until
three o'clock this afternoon but i think
it will still take some time for some of
the winds to obey it we'll still be
under an amber warning for 60 70 mile
per hour gusts until nine o'clock
tonight so i know it sounds like we're
going on and on and on about the strong
winds but it really is quite exceptional
storm units it's very strong something
called explosive cyclogenesis where the
pressure depends really rapidly
causing this effect you can see here
just how strong and gusty the winds are
and it doesn't take much for such strong
winds to have an impact on our
infrastructure on travel on housing
already i've heard reports of tiles
being blown off and starting quite
lethal here in the window i'm hoping not
to see any of my neighbors trampolines
fly past but on more serious no already
seen the winds reaching 122 miles per
hour
on the needles in the isle of wight and
yes that's a very exposed location
across many parts of the uk throughout
the day the focus of course is in the
south but it really is not looking good